we have a discussion forum of sorts at
on reddit at david pakman.com slash read
it that's our EDD IT we now have
somewhere around 21,000 of our viewers
and listeners subscribed there and there
were three posts I spotted this morning
with similar themes when it comes to the
November election and some of this is
reassuring but I also want to talk about
sort of the cautionary aspects of it so
user the final play down posted only one
will be President
I choose Biden and I'm reassured to some
degree that a lot of the very loud
voices that for months ago were saying
Biden's not progressive enough if it's
not Bernie or not Tulsi or whoever you
know yang then I kind of don't care if
it's Trump or Biden or a lot of those
voices I'm not hearing from anymore and
what I am hearing is you know I now
understand the importance of removing
Donald Trump and I'm glad to see that
use their wagon wheel what had a similar
post which was this election is pretty
simple a majority of Americans are
suffering and sick and tired of Trump's
stick and Biden is a more palatable
moderate alternative it's very sober
right it's not Biden is the future of
the progressive movement it's we have to
remove Donald Trump that's the take away
and I I'm sort of to some degree
reassured by seeing this and then a
third post also this one from wagon
wheel what is do you think Trump has
given up the announcement about leaving
the World Health Organization just seems
like a burn it all to the ground move
I'm getting more and more messages about
that which is does Trump even really
want to win is Trump trying to torpedo
his own reelection I think that it's not
a dangerous path to go down but it's one
that if we go too far down it could
dissuade people from voting and listen
Trump what what we know about Trump is
that he's an extreme narcissist with
significant delusions of grandeur and I
don't believe that in any conscious way
Trump is going to throw in the towel or
not try to win what I do believe will
happen is if Trump loses he's gonna do
what narcissists do is he's not going to
really accept it as an actual defeat
Trump will say I never really wanted
this anyway I gave you four years I made
the country great again if you want Joe
Biden I'm gonna go I'm still rich I'm
the best businessman I'm gonna build
buildings or whatever else the case may
be he's never going to see it as really
a defeat because he is an extreme
narcissist but I think anybody thinking
Trump's throwing in the towel are not
really going to try to win we are going
to see over the next four months a
significant significant escalation in
Trump's erratic nature and yes he's
going to try to win and every single one
of us has to vote which is why we're
going to talk about polling momentarily
I invite you to join the discussion on
the subreddit at david pakman.com slash
our EDD i.t
we have moderators you are not going to
get bullied or if someone tries to bully
you we're gonna cut that crap out it's
it's a place for respectful discussion
and I invite you to join us